- Former President, Trump,
has sued basically all of social media
for de-platforming him.
He has sued Twitter, Facebook, and YouTube
claiming that they somehow
violated the first amendment
by kicking him off of their platforms.
This is going to fail spectacularly.
Number one, he filed as a class action.
This is not a class action.
Second of all, you, the viewer
seem to know more about section 230
of the Communications Decency Act
than former President
Trump and his lawyers.
It doesn't do the things
that he says it does.
It's the first amendment that allows them
to kick him off of their
platform, it's not section 230.
And this whole thing may be sanctionable.
Former President Trump
filed suit in Florida
which has an anti-slap law.
It's not a particularly
strong one, but it does exist.
So this whole lawsuit may be
kicked out on an anti-slap.
So we'll see if we see them in court.